good evening and welcome to that gyrus
today Brad Jones joins the riffing as
they take a look at a short film that's
about appropriately enough snobs sit
back and enjoy quick draw mcgraw here
I'm here to talk about ostracizing
others in the name of conformity
discussion problems in group living like
why is Joan Rivers I the title card the
Brad Jones story how you two can make a
living reviewing poor
I can't wait till the 50s and so we can
invent real dancing peeping Rob Petch
Reese's Laura for the first time
aggression extra nine -
therefore a equals I need a boyfriend a
lousy Young Republicans rally I wish
those Mormons would shut up by the time
you read this I will be gone
having plummeted off the winter river
bridge are you doing math in there no
are you playing to commit suicide maybe
good as long as it's not math hi mom
Oh got any whiskey Hill working so late
on Friday night you're a loser it's my
last algebra problem just save my
history until tomorrow Sarah your father
and I want to have sex so I need to
spell it out anymore appreciate the fact
that you take your schoolwork seriously
cool work but well couldn't you manage
to arrange your time so you could have a
little fun to you know put out I have a
certain amount of homework to do I like
get it done on time but you have the
whole weekend sleep with something you
could go out on Friday night or have
somebody in right then is that what you
mean having a good time is all I mean I
will what's my life story why I talked
to Ron's mother yeah well I suppose
you'd fix it so he'd have to invite me
over if I fixed you mean bribed if it
had been necessary but I found out that
those Friday night get-togethers or open
houses you can go I'll provide the Billy
beer I could if I wanted to I don't I
think you should go you're only young
ones eager you're only gonna look 40 at
seventeen once there's nobody over there
I want to see there'll be algebra there
lots of algebra I think I better finish
my algebra just remember x equals lonely
old cat lady we'll talk about this some
other time
oh and you know what then
dear mr. Disney I think hubby may have
touched me inappropriately please alert
the other Mouseketeers PS I think Donald
is a Nazi all right we're here to record
our new hit single Wonder Bread why do
they have an entire wall made out of
Rubik's cubes - hey
maybe we can find out what's going on
inside the building your friends are
certainly a nice bunch on yeah the
greatest whatever they work you suppose
they'd like to help you do something
really nice what do you mean huh
well how about being more friendly to
Sarah inman Sarah inland Oh mom she's a
whore I mean it how you could invite
Sarah over here next Friday to join us
Greta come over here well gee whiz what
don't you dare use that language water
to go no cover on Howard's first attempt
at a comb-over Sarah inland now Ron you
know we've always said that all of your
friends are welcome here at anytime
except the darkies mom but well the idea
just kind of grew we've got a large game
room well-stocked refrigerator lots a
good record plenty of booze yeah for me
to ask you about that words all my booze
nobody needed to be asked but Sarah
never teen she's too high hat for that
she wants a special invitation now look
here on years ago when you had rheumatic
fever don't you remember who it was who
came over here every day and read to you
by the hour
cuz I don't sure mom but he's changed
since then oh no Ron I don't think she's
really changed she's still flat why
don't you give her a chance no no she
was good to me once I know oh she's
experience I guess I can ask her to
honor us with her present let me move my
bong here I'll call her tomorrow
Thanks fun now about your genital warts
mom you know growing up brings different
problems to different people and some
well they just don't quite bring it off
without falling down somewhere
times you don't feel your freshest scuse
me where sara fell down was when she
went in the junior high of course she
had a penis then he was in grade school
she she was swell he made good grades
and had lots of friends but when she
started going to junior high with lots
of other sharp kids she was less swell
big wheel now she's in senior high oh
there's no swelled mess about her at all
it seems well you know it sounds like
she needs a friend
you're nominating me I will not accept
my mother's nomination he may cut me dad
she does lots of other people
giggity-giggity and I don't think she
cares at all I think she's a dare I say
it
snob Oh get a hold of yourself there are
no snobs they don't exist you hear me
hmm her Highness has nice weather oh
it's delicious you've got a hand in to
Sarah she certainly has good day she'll
hear you that's an awful pretty sweater
Sarah
well don't be sorry I was just
calculating the odds of not decapitating
you with my map book
here nobody see nobody I'm going like
that we'll kill your brother
no no one-handed well it's nice they
overcame their racial differences to
fight a common enemy
but we're mostly election for next year
student council officer bill Tyler made
president I voted for Hubert Humphrey
I'll see ya
I suppose you don't think Bill's the
best man for the job I like Mike oh that
girl she just saw because we picked
built design for the yearbook cover
instead of hers well it was a swastika I
can't believe they didn't like my
Tibetan good luck symbol I know you
shoot us all out of the kitchen but I
don't mind trying dude even though I
don't have tits to do it with sighs I
wanted to talk to you pumpkin man even
I'm jealous of this guy's voice during
dinner something's bothering you care to
cry on my shoulder you're a chick that's
all you do right cry that up wonderful
thing Oh lots of little things we could
talk about you know like the barn it
wouldn't do any good
we have ducting cover and that's all we
need I'm waiting where's my dinner all
right I'm preggers you'll think I'm
silly I I actually sort of liked the
ending to lost spit it up thing that's
not my son this morning when I came to
class I was worried about the history
test first period you had your first
period what I was going over it in my
mind somebody spoke to me Nancy Hager
Jagr that's what the Mia was missing her
but she said she looked at me as if she
just hated me
I was also crow Phi at each era but that
was nothing
well maybe you could I worked hard on a
history test but I loved it
well maybe if I don't study as hard as I
do for hopes may come off with the a
guitar honey I'm smarter than they are I
know I am yes but they're not watching
the paper plates um they're there last
week I I worked just hours and hours on
design for the yearbook cover
oh god you went with a swastika didn't
you primer hand in just a blotchy sketch
I couldn't see anything to it just a
yellow face I said have a nice day his
design is going to be on a yearbook
cover isn't fair this afternoon wrong
for next door called by me over Friday
night that bastard I had to say yes
because mother's been pressuring me but
I don't want to go all the kids that get
by on apple-polishing will be there too
and I don't like them punkin your
dessert needs more pumpkin I'm sorry you
don't like so many people but shut up
friends are important in this world you
should encourage others to make good and
not dislike them for it now have you
thought about getting some real problems
there's right I think you should go to
Ron's get-together this Friday
try to like people for whatever they are
cuz that's what the 50's did best
tolerance addition I can clean out the
sink I have no daughter
okay punkin just one more question why
are you washing the dishes before we eat
all these people you don't like
finally happier than you are yeah but
that's because I'm not usually with them
aren't they happier than you are yeah I
heard you the first time to add
aren't they happier you stop shouting
for the bathroom I can hear you from
here
meanwhile the exact same party at the
exact same house with the exact same
dance steps is taking place at the exact
same time
I don't know I don't think it's white
enough first choice goes to our new pet
who wants a butternut and Lucky Strike
sandwich playing up - oh look at it with
his 18 year old bald spot yeah I can see
this is the party for the adult where's
the party for the kids I'm just as good
as he is no I'm better he'll get no
playing up from me I'm gonna give him
the steering of a lifetime to the
Eisenhower
huh what are they gonna invent alcohol
oh I think those mountain dew is
starting to kick in
well I'm swelled boy I didn't know what
she's gonna wear first me or the music I
think your hair is the first to give out
a chick ignoring me let's see what these
skittles have to say about that hey how
about it you want dance I'd rather not
well you want to sit and talk then I'd
rather not not with you that's because
my hair looks like a skunk isn't it I'm
sorry man I'm gonna go sit on a bench
and eat chocolates are you satisfied a
concerned Paul Lynn it comes to help out
talking about you really froze him out
didn't you piece of stiff as an icicle
well I think you did want to dance you
wanted to dance all right but you just
couldn't pass up the chance to be us no
oh that is my word
smells nuts nuts nuts nuts nuts now
thus began her fascination with Bruno
Matai movies sir come back
yeah she said the S word of the matter
can I do anything no it's okay my
favorite movie is Caligula - they're so
mean and hateful why is it so mean that
anybody was one of their gay than you
all the silly things they do maybe if
I'm I'm ill with this tree the snob
hurting everyone herself her parents her
friends other people
what makes Sarah act the way she does
education and wanting to learn or some
lack she feels in her cell or was she
just born independent can a friend like
Ron help her in any way he could assist
her with her suicide is the group
justified has he got the second base yet
has he taken her bra off yes
what do you think as usual we presented
to be continued that will not be
continued
today's logical equation ladies thinking
equals snobby well can I get just a
linear stop